et pour en parler nous sommes avec
frédéric bizarre économiste de la santé
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france
première question est ce que ce ségur de
la santé peuvent vraiment aboutir on
voit que ça se passe pas très bien
en tout cas pour tous les syndicats sud
santé notamment à claquer la porte
je crois que frank un problème de de
dimensionnement d'un petit peu de cette
négociation pourquoi est ce que le
gouvernement s'est précipité sur
l'organisation d'une telle d'une telle
initiative c'est que tout simplement il
y avait un risque politique
vous avez les soignants qui ont d'abord
vous avez une crise sociale depuis
plusieurs mois l'hôpital mais publie il
vous avez une crise sociale sur
l'ensemble de notre système de santé
vraiment les français prennent
conscience que c'est de notre système de
santé qui est en crise
non pas parce qu'il est mauvais mais
parce qu'il n'a pas été adaptée aux
enjeux du 21e siècle rappelle que en
2000 l'om est ce que vous avez donné le
rôle de premier système de santé dans le
monde numéro deux était d'été l'italie
et on voit vraiment après on a été un
des pays qui a le plus le plus mal réagi
en tout cas qu'il était le moins que moi
bien préparés à la crise sanitaire
or le gouvernement aujourd'hui fait face
à un risque de crise politique avec des
soignants notamment à l'hôpital public
qui ont pris 1 qui ont un capital
politique important parce que ici moins
extrêmement populaires ils ont été
applaudis pendant trois mois
au final de l'ensemble des français et
donc là il ya un vrai risque et les
soignants compte bien si vous voulez
utiliser ce capital politique donc on a
mis en place
c'est dur de la santé mais qui n'est
qu'une négociation salariale à l'hôpital
public
donc vous avez aujourd'hui beaucoup de
soignants qui tombe de haut parce qu'il
pensait qu'on allait repenser l'ensemble
du système de santé et qu'on allait
avoir véritablement une restructuration
globale
or finalement ils s'aperçoivent que on
est sur une négociation avec des
contraintes très fortes budgétaire donc
je crois qu'ils se sont trompés qui va
falloir revoir dimensionnement ça veut
dire qu'on est incapable aujourd'hui de
vraiment remords danese et refonder ce
système en profondeur parce que c'est
évidemment ça l'urgence contre
évidemment de mieux payer ces soignants
ça veut dire qu'on a renoncé à sa part
ce qu'on nous dit on n'a plus d'argent
dans les tests justement il ne faut pas
tout revoir
et vous avez les principales mesures
sont des mesures qui sont nos coûteuse
et non risqués politiquement le seul
problème les principales mesures et
d'ailleurs les soignants le dis souvent
c'est quand même qu'il faut des des
administrés le système il faut des
techno des technocrates is et le système
terre-lune à un système qui est devenu
extrêmement bureaucratique parce qu'un
état a pris le contrôle de ce système on
avait un système de santé qui était
relativement décentralisées comme l'est
par exemple au système allemand qui a
bien réagi c'est à dire que vous avez
une capacité de réaction à la fois pour
soigner les gens mais aussi quand vous
alliez des crises sanitaires qui était
beaucoup plus importante maintenant
notre système est ultra centralisé ultra
bureaucratise ultra bureaucratisé ça
c'est la mère des réformes qu'il faut
faire cette réforme elle est non
coûteuse et elle elle sera elle aura le
support de l'opinion publique
simplement elle à une opposition très
forte ou coeur de
organisation politique c'est la haute
administration qui dans mon peuple et
donc c'est le pouvoir politique il ne
veut pas aller dans cette direction là
donc vous avez une espèce de blocage qui
est fait encore on aime on a essayé de
fuir vous poser la question simplement
pourquoi n'en at il pas parce que voilà
ils ont conscience sont encore restés là
je comprends parce que c'est toujours
compliqué si vous voulez à comprendre
mais pourquoi alors que si c'est pas
très compliqué tout simplement parce que
notre système de santé
c'est pas seul système social le système
d'organisation de notre société
il est piloté par l'administration de
poids politique on le voit lorsque vous
avez un changement de ministre vous
voyez bien que le la politique de santé
change à peine que ça soit de gauche ou
de droite on a eu notre administration
qui tient les rênes du système et ses
taux d'administration d' absolument
parents de confier le pouvoir comme les
soignants le demande comme les patients
le monde à une organisation de
démocratie sanitaire
et pourtant la solution c'est celle ci
donc là on est en train de cibler les
distraire un petit peu pas le public de
distraire les soignants sur quelque
chose qui ne correspond pas au coeur de
la réforme
donc nous y était que ce que ce séguret
la santé soit une mascarade par la
posture utilisé beaucoup de monde mais
en est on alors de pas le coeur de la
réforme nécessaire pour que notre
système de santé redevienne performant
démocratie sanitaire qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire par la famille bizarre qui
détiendrait le vrai pouvoir les hôpitaux
et pas des directeurs d'hôpitaux
concrètement on dit qu'il faut
décloisonner système qu'il faut sortir
le système hospitalo centre et elle vous
voyez bien qu'on se précipite à faire la
réforme qui concerne l'hôpital public
donc il est bien quand on est un rare de
ré hospitalisé et dirt 3 zones et le
système de toute façon c'est même bien
échec par rapport à l'objectif de
décloisonnement qui est lié au fait que
oui il faut raisonner par rapport à un
parcours du patient par contre d'une
question qui est magique
herman en ville et qui va l on va dire
en dernier ressort à l'hôpital public le
monde a radicalement changé par rapport
aux ordonnances debré de 2,58 donc la
démocratie sanitaire c'est très simple
la dsi il faut qu'il ya un état qui soit
stratège il faut que l'état définisse
une politique de santé publique
il faut que l'état définisse des
priorités de santé publique il faut que
l'état soit capable d'évaluer
l'évolution des besoins de la population
tout ça c'est indispensable à la santé
publique à l'échelle de la population
on a vu qu'il ya une désorganisation
complète que la santé publique
aujourd'hui avec une multitude d'agents
ce n'est qu'ils sont inaudibles
on l'a vu quand il ya besoin vraiment de
conseils scientifiques très pointues on
avait vous aviez une multitude de
médecins qui avaient des avis divergents
mais il n'y a pas la chance crédible
auprès du grand public
donc ça il faut le créer la deuxième
chose c'est que les soins doivent être
piloté l'échelle des territoires dire
qu'il faut définir des territoires de
santé dont la loi qui représente la
nouvelle unité géographique à partir de
laquelle vous allez avoir une
organisation au sein d'instituts santé
que façon de recherche qui réfléchit sur
l'évolution du système de santé
on a proposé un système de collège une
forme de parlements les chaînes du
territoire qui est la responsabilité de
la l'exécution de la politique de santé
qui est défini à l'échelle qui est
défini par le gouvernement michelot qui
voit la leaf ou ce qu'on avait fait
autrefois dans les hautes qui pilotait
les et les autres fois les autres fois
les autres il ya 20 30 ans dans les
hôpitaux c'est lé chef de service alors
on critiquait le mandarinat mixa avait
au moins intéressés que vous aviez une
gestion proche du terrain proche du
patient qui était très décentralisé donc
il faut retrouver une gestion
décentralisée de notre système de soins
et il faut que l'état soit fort dans sa
vie
son régaliennes définition d'une
politique de santé ambitieuse et de
l'évaluation des produits et des
prestations de santé
vous voyez c'est ce à quoi s'est passé
panetta doit disparaître c'est l'état
doivent être fort doit être fort et nous
a délégué la ville doit déléguer délégué
à 1 me elle n'est mocratie sanitaires
merci beaucoup aux frédéric il ya des
arts d'avoir été avec nous pour évoquer
ce ségur de la santé c'est magnifique